hello and welcome to three scary games
this is the least scariest thing i could
have ever done it's three scary games
here's a jump scare
is that good elixir because that's
something you can work with
now we're coming up on the hundredth
episode it'll be whoa
that one
spooky anyway i'm gonna play some games
now and they're scary and there's three
of them
maybe press any key to begin bam
this is
the bus home home bus i literally just
saw the name and i don't remember what
it was but you need to take a bus and go
home
a bugs
about four minutes left do i
[Music]
do i just wait here do i wait here for
the if i wait here for the bus
is it
am i not gonna die
i feel like it this is the die zone
i feel like this is death oh no
okay invisible wall maybe i do just wait
for the bus i feel like there has to be
more to it than this
three minutes nope this is um
this is a sit and wait for a bus okay um
lixian google short scary story and then
find one of the first stories that you
find and run it through a text-to-speech
and play it for me
we bought an old house my boyfriend and
i
he's in charge of the new construction
converting the kitchen into the master
bedroom for instance while i'm on
wallpaper removal duty
just another person waiting for the bus
okay
hey bro
two minutes left okay all right you
wanna wait with me where did you come
from
that was weird god i thought you were
gonna kill me
anyway back to my scary story
the previous owner papered every wall in
ceiling removing it is brutal but oddly
satisfying the best feeling is getting a
long peel similar to your skin when
you're peeling from a sunburn under a
corner section of paper in every room is
a person's name and a date curiosity got
the best of me one night when i googled
one of the names and discovered the
person was actually a missing person the
missing date matching the day under the
wallpaper hey hey hey kid
what bring you talking to me what brings
you here so late
uh waiting for the bus
you're not a tucker are you i mean
listen to a story how about this how
about no have a bottle of beer with me
maybe that can change your mind
about what
about what changed my mind about what
come on take a sip
no not gonna take a drink from a
stranger and i am apparently
underage and can't drink
so no anyway back to my story the next
day i made a list of all the names and
dates sure enough each name was for a
missing person with dates to match
we notified the police who naturally
sent out the crime scene team
i overheard one text say yup it's human
human
what's human ma'am where is the material
you removed from the walls already this
isn't wallpaper you are removing
you will regret this one
why would i regret this one
why would i regret it
get off i'm going to get on i'm going to
get on the bus
i mean i'm safely
oh my god okay oh
i'm back here
what if he never sees me what if he
never sees me what if i
and the one lurking in the distance and
he he
is the one that is snuck upon
he will never see me you'll never find
me
he'll never find me because i'm in the
brush
i am in the brush
don't mind me
sorry uh
why are you out at night hey you know
you know
you don't want to talk do you uh you
know you you're saying different words
than you did before in the other
alternate reality how about this oh you
got some sweet beer bro you got some
beer bro
bro
bro
bro
give me a swig give me a sweet swig of
that
yeah give me that yeah
uh oh i went missing everybody was it
okay
all right well that didn't go too good
what if i'm in his spot
and he can't get here
hello
hello
[Laughter]
well you got a problem huh
all right then
so the other ending is either getting
hit by the bus or not getting on the bus
at all which if i do get hit by the bus
would mean that i don't get
on the bus if i get hit by the bus i
don't get on the bus
that's the perfect plan it's foolproof
i also might have bugged him out by oh
never mind
oh you know i don't know
got a story i'ma listen to
i don't know why i looked up but when i
did i saw him there he stood against my
window his forehead rested against the
glass and his eyes were still in light
and he smiled a lipstick red cartoonish
grin my wife was upstairs sleeping my
son was in his crib and i couldn't move
i froze and watched him looking past me
through the glass his smile never moved
but he put a hand up and slid it down
the glass watching me i couldn't do
anything i just stayed there frozen feet
still in the bush as i was pruning
looking into my home he stood against my
window
i will regret this one why will i regret
this one
i guess i
regret that
well damn but i didn't get the third
ending i guess i gotta find it
last night a friend rushed me out of the
house to catch the opening act at a
local bars music night after a few
drinks i realized my phone wasn't in my
pocket i checked the table we were
sitting at the bar the bathrooms and
after no luck i used my friend's phone
to call mine after two rings someone
answered gave out a low raspy giggle and
hung up they didn't answer again i
eventually gave it up as a lost cause
and headed home i found my phone laying
on my nightstand right where i left it
i'm making a mistake am i
what if i don't get on the bus
what if i just wait here what if i don't
want to be on the bus
what if the bus is the mistake
huh
what do you think about that okay bye
boss oh god bus wait babe
boss
bus
um
oh boy hey mal i thought you were gonna
get on the bus
well this is awkward
i think that maybe i judged you too
harshly pal
that's the last bus
[Music]
um
oh i've been stabbed
got
stabbed
all right well uh
i guess uh what was i really expecting
all right so very fun i liked that a lot
it was very simple but at the same time
it was spooky it only had like one good
scare in it but that was all the scare
needed it was just the uncomfortableness
of the situation that i found very very
troublesome but good
moving on
why did i say it like that
this is radio disturbance
there's some disturbance on a radio mode
story dive next spot i don't know what
that means info redacted
that's a convenient way to do story
report in scout 12 reporting in
coordinates been transmitted
make my way to him and what what am i
supposed to look for
mask oh
okay
complain
man i've seen nothing but concrete since
i got here
at least tell me if i should expect
something
[Music]
okay do i have coordinates or
weird
okay
oh god
what am i even looking
at space to jump okay
i'm just happening
like there's wind in my ear
what the [ __ ] what was that
hello
i can't fit my fat ass through this gap
i legit can't fit my fat ass through
that gap
oh god how was i supposed to be able to
see that
it's in pitch blackness all right
whatever
command scout 12 reporting in there's
nothing here just one of the airlock
doors
that's transit scanner said
it's got 12 are you sure there's nothing
there
yes i'm sure it's just more concrete
what do you mean
what do you mean
what
i'm not going to report it
i'm not going to report it
it's got 12 his failure to respond scott
13d to copy
not reporting in
not reporting in
it's a trap
goddamn trap
oh my god hello
why are you dead
why are you dead
is that me please tell me that's not me
okay squeezy very squishy um what wha
what is happening here help
help me
help me
help
am i dead
well i'm confused
um i feel like i've done something
horribly wrong
and it's not gonna work anymore i'm
gonna hang on let me restart this i'm
very confused let's try that again
on my way anything else to note
negative
okay
you got it pal
thanks command love you bye
there's some offshoots here
well i'm dead
there's nobody here
[Music]
just more concrete
[Music]
what do you mean get out of here
all right
why is there nobody here right now what
if i say nothing what if i what if i say
nothing
i'm dead again
why
i'm so confused
scout 13.
what wait wait oh
wait i'm scout 13 now
is that why the dead body was there wait
a minute i'm confused
oh it's open
interesting
uh
this is 13 i found 12.
k.i.a
airlock it's uh it's open
uh it's open big papa
uh big pop in the command chair uh
it's open baby
oh hi
why would i run
oh god command we have a problem we have
a problem we have a problem
oh i fell
where am i oh oh
oh god
man coming command
i got some booze
i think i just fell through the floor
what is going on here
oh no
oh no
this isn't the back rooms
this is the under croft okay well at
least i can get drunk i guess
sure wish i could why would you do that
why would you do that
why would you say noise like that
why would you do noise like that
why why do you keep doing that
oh okay that's different
okay up
no
ah oh uh oh okay
um
ah connection terminated awaiting input
what did they do
whoa
i got some equipment running how did
this even get down here we heard your
loud and clear 13.
great mind tell me what's going on now
let me go get off authorization one
moment
she may have noticed this not your
regular government facility
we have no idea what it is in fact
but we do know that it goes on much
further than it should be possible
and that the laws of physics as we know
them do not apply in the same way
all right we've tried to explore and set
up permanent camps but those have failed
so we put scouts on the edges of
explored territory to patrol for any
changes
that's all i would have thought there
was a larger conspiracy here or
something
that's a bit of a relief i suppose
regardless we have a plan to get you out
of here and i will you won't like it
there's an entrance point about three
zones down from you you need to work
your way there but be careful we haven't
explored the territory in between
i've opened the airlock good luck we
have no idea what you'll find
all right
great roger that or whatever
i'm on my way i think oh god
oh that's not good
he oh
gun
i get gun
yeah all right
you want to mess with me
huh
you want tussle
with a muscle and try me
whoa
hey
[Applause]
you ain't tussling
you ain't muscling
we're never gonna get the tussle on this
muscle
oh why
why
too many
i don't like it also my signal is not
blooping so i'm thinking i'm in the
wrong place
yeah backtrack a bit
okay damn it i made it my way back all
right
oh my thing died that's what happened
oh okay them hey
oh
that's fine
all right
don't know what that was about
yeah whatever idiot
what stupid
i'm getting out of here
huh
easy
i'm sorry this is probably nauseating
for everyone at home going through the
darkness
it is for me too
[Music]
oh hey stop it
go away
are you where i need to be you are
aren't you
[Music]
okay i'm gonna guess that i don't need
to go that way
because my god i can't see anything
anyway
oh that's not good
okay that's weird
well that's horrifying but i'm just
gonna go i guess
there's no point
okay goodbye i guess i can't see
anything
and there's nothing okay um i think this
game might be incomplete so i'm gonna
give this guy a big ol hug
come here
all right so i'm gonna leave that one
there that was good but man it is tough
to play with that sway i'm hoping that
lixie can cut out a lot of it because it
was just so nauseating it was just like
a blue it was seasickness simulator that
being said i did kind of like what it
was going for it got me a few times and
it did feel like it was i mean it feel
it felt pretty cool i really liked it it
was very very fun so
that was good
but moving on
this is the other side something about
maintaining a drill to get out of a
shelter or something like that i'm not
exactly sure shelter number one official
civil guidelines you do not talk about
going outside you do not think about
going outside this place keeps us safe
from the dangers of the outside out
there is death out there is nothing i
believed that once until an explosion
unfolded on the surface level the crowd
that gathered there they all saw and
nobody was surprised when they were
missing the next day to keep people in a
metal box one must show power but they
forgot one person and i saw all right
it's time to leave i'm a little confused
was there an explosion that killed
everybody outside and now i need to go
outside and get exploded
whoa
oh
cool left click e q escape everything i
need to start drilling is here to get
started i should use a computer
very iron long ask
which i love and there's been a lot of
love for iron lung lately very cool
hello
casing parent calibration checking
horizon oh insert drill into casing for
a diagnostic report
i have a drill
what is the uh thingamabob you were
talking about
oh
insert drill into casing
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god okay yeah maybe i shouldn't go
outside maybe going outside would be a
very bad idea
did you ever think about that
did you ever think about that that maybe
going outside wasn't the best idea in
the world hello okay let me try um
i think i gotta open this bad boy up or
something
nope
hammer
please insert battery huh
oh god what did i do
ah battery
charge in progress 100 okay that's
uh
okay um what about you no that's broken
drill all right
insert drill into casing for diagnostics
report
oh oh
the whole drill got i thought i was
thinking drill bit ah okay
let's see what have we got
whoa
hold secure battery is not inserted
drilling in a unable to start error okay
i took the battery out because i was
dumb
okay batteries charged
pop that in there
lock her down
pop her in
unlock here we go
diagnostics
okay let's continue drilling in progress
keep safe distance from the casing
drilling will automatically stop when an
error is found in the diagnostic system
am i sure i want to do this
e
am i absolutely sure
oh
oh
drill bit function
oh [ __ ]
okay um wow yeah that popped right off
okay
so i need to get the drill bit open
let me go ahead and charge the battery
while it's doing this thing
okay it's fine i think i feel like it's
this tool
all right new drill bit going in
good thing i got plenty of these stop
that baby
bad boy in here
all right
full blam
all right let's keep going i guess but
again i want to emphasize why do i
think that this is the best idea
i feel like they put up all these metal
walls for good reason and that maybe i
shouldn't
maybe i shouldn't go
outside
i hate this dark room back here
that's something that iron lung did too
just like having that in the background
just like not okay battery i just
charged up the battery
i just made sure it was all good
oh my god
um
oh
boy
is that outside
remember how everyone else died or
something or whatever it was i don't
really know i don't really care uh
inside indoors
indoors
that's where it's safe
[Music]
this is not a good idea
or at least this feels like it's not a
good idea
why does it feel like it's not a good
idea
oh my god
oil level
really probably gonna pop open the top
casing or something with this
yep
okay all right give me the blue
all right give me the red
why are they what
i don't know what that was
i find
okay
in we go
i'm just gonna sit in the dark room
until it's done
very uncomfortable
very
uncomfortable i am very uncomfortable
[Music]
okay we done did we do it
oh
layer one of two drill press any key to
start drilling layer two okay final
layer will activate shelter security
measures reminder there is no coming
back press any key to confirm
one two three four five my confirmation
code was p-e-n-i-s
[Music]
okay
i guess i'm going what other choice do i
have is i i don't think i have food here
oh my god
oh no
oh no
oh go go go go go go go go why are you
doing this
what are you what are you talking about
i hate this i hate this
i hate this oh i hate this
i hate this
go baby go baby i'm getting out of here
oh okay
oh it's really blasting through
oh god why okay i'm not gonna waste any
time
okay let's can i have it please thank
you pop this off battery get it in the
charger already what was the other
problem drill bit function okay i need
the other tool i need this give
slam new drill bit in the thing put that
in there
slam that away battery's charging come
on baby come on this is the most
stressful music i've ever heard in
oregon oh you're charging so slowly
there we go
slam bam wham unlock put it back in the
boob
oh come on come on
come on come on come on come on come on
go
oh my god come on
i don't even know what they mean by
security
what is the security i thought i was the
only one left
i thought i was the only one here and
also how do they not know about any of
this that's happening in this room how
do they not know about this
oh what is wrong what is wrong give me
give give give give give i'll look at it
in a second oh my god really give what's
the problem cool in oil easy easy easy
problem to fix
come on oh lock it in come on
okay it was red on the left i remember
this
and blue on the right i remember that
put it back down grab the screwy drivey
put it back
unlock it let's go baby let's go go go
go go
ah
yeah i'm stressed
i'm stressed
[Music]
come on
okay oil battery charge okay easy i got
that i got that
first thing i'm gonna do get the battery
in there charging up and going because
that's important then i'm gonna get this
working on that while that's happening
well i'll get the other one all right
and then while that's happening i'm
gonna grab this
put that away
slam that in there i'll grab another
drill bit pop her in bam done put that
away red in the red
red and the red
blue in the blue
and then by the time that's done i pop
these back on battery's almost done
charging battery is done charging grab
that
put that away grab that slam that on
back in good to go go baby go
easy peasy species go go go go go go
i don't know why i'm going outside to
certain doom but i am and i love it
please tell me you're actually gonna
finish do not stop right at the end
there go all the way to the end
oh i love you drill i love you
ah
[Music]
made it
plenty of time
whoa
oh
freedom
wow
oh my god
holy crap
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow tree
oh
this place isn't what it look
the rest of the note is unintelligible
what what what
what
why oh oh my god no
oh no
oh no let me back in
oh no
oh no let me back in
oh my god
as it turned out the other side was
death
omnibus not very good i like that he
told the story man he told the story
very cool
very cool very stressful and a lot of
fun and that's all i can really uh want
out of a horror game
scary game is what it is and that was
very good and that wraps up our three
scary games for today hope you enjoyed
it here comes the scariest scare you've
ever seen
just get ready
you can't even believe the kind of
terror that's coming your way
but before you get the terror if you
want more scary games link is in the
description there's a giant playlist
check him out okay
hit him lixian
[Music]
you